There is some super interesting geopolitics
that have developed around the recent piece.
Seven meetings. There's going to be a lot
of g talk today
and the obvious stuff remains obvious, right?
I mean, Trump is in competent, he's undiplomatic,
he's ignorant. He is effectively a petulant
child on the world stage. But you've got to
sort of hand it to the guy. He's creating
some pretty damn interesting scenarios. Now,
as you know, Donald Trump abandoned the Iran
nuclear deal. This was an Obama era deal.
Iran abided by its rules. Trump never liked
the deal. Trump has been wanting to abandon
anything that has Barack Obama's name or signature
on it. So Donald Trump bailed on that deal
and as expected, Iran immediately said, well,
if you're out, we'll start doing nuclear research
again. Why wouldn't we if we did nothing wrong,
and yet your such an unreliable partner in
treaties, the U s under Donald Trump that
you bail. We'll just go back to doing what's
in our best interests. And Donald Trump said,
well, hold on a second.
We bailed on the deal, but you still have
to abide by it because there are other European
countries that are still in it. A very strange
geopolitical attempt to sort of have your
cake and eat it too. And I told you from day
one, this is a disaster and it's completely
shortsighted, very much like Donald Trump's
China tariffs as we're now seeing. But there
is now something very interesting happening
with Iran. Iran, his foreign minister flew
to be a rich this weekend for the g seven
sideline meetings. The meetings happening
on the sidelines of the official [inaudible].
Iran is not part of the g seven, but their
foreign minister was there. And we've now
learned that Iran is foreign minister met
with his French counterpart and French president.
McCrone has now drawn a line in the sand saying,
hold on a second. France, Britain, Germany
and Japan. We want to do diplomacy.
We want to figure this thing out. The U S
has bailed. Trump has completely abandoned
a deal that Iran, uh, followed the rules of.
But now France and the other three countries
remaining are going to try to do diplomacy.
They're going to try to convince Iran not
to start violating the deal. And meanwhile,
Emmanuel Macron and friends are going to push
Donald Trump not to sanction Iran more and
more and to put a de facto blockade on petroleum
sales. This is France jumping in and effectively
upstaging Donald Trump. What McCrone is trying
to do fascinating because of the middleman
position that he's created for himself and
for friends. On the one hand, he's looking
to get Iran to do what it was that the deal
successfully put in place anyway. And Iran
stuck to, uh, for the duration that Donald
Trump, uh, was in the deal that the u s was
in the deal, which is don't do nuclear development.
On the other hand, Emmanuel Macron is saying,
we'll be on your side, Iran. We as the adults
left in the deal, France, Germany, Britain,
Japan, we will try to convince that petulant
child, Donald Trump, to stop the sanctions
and to stop the escalation against you. And
I told you that this was happening with global
climate change discussions. And it is, and
I'll have a story about that for you on today's
show, but the world is increasingly going
around Trump, not just on climate change.
They are seeing him as the petulant obstacle
that you have to get around rather than work
with. And it's not just with climate change
here, it's happening with foreign policy and
geopolitics and nuclear proliferation or trying
to prevent the nuclear proliferation. Other
people have figured it out. They don't actually
need Trump to make things happen beyond just
needing to placate Trump and get them out
of the way.
Just enough to get Donald Trump out of the
way. How out of place must Trump feel at these
g seven things? Everybody else is educated
and worldly and diplomatic. They listened
to advisers. They listened to their intelligence
experts. They understand geopolitics and incomes.
Donald Trump, who cheats at golf and sexually
harasses dozens of women. Trump maybe doesn't
even realize how out of place he actually
is and good from a crone. Now, uh, he's doing
the right thing here. He's doing what's in
the best interests more broadly of not only
the participants in the Iran nuclear deal,
but quite frankly of the world. Iran was abiding
by the deal. You can have a broader conversation
about if the U s gets to have nukes, why doesn't
Iran get to have them? That's a conversation
some in my audience want to have and that's
a perfectly reasonable, reasonable conversation
to have to the extent that we had this deal.
And to the extent that we don't want Iran
to obtain nuclear weapons, which I don't,
and I'm glad to talk about that further if
the reasons why aren't obvious. Um, but they
were abiding by the deal they were doing their
part and Donald Trump willy nilly said, we're
out good from a crone. Let's now talk about
the fiasco that was Trump at the g seven related
to climate change completely predictably.